the NHS is in crisis from GPS to
hospitals ambulances to long-term care
the system is buckling a Service
established nearly 75 years ago to serve
the public from Cradle to grave is
itself in need of urgent care tonight we
ask can the NHS survive every bed in
every Bay is full patients waiting
several hours in ambulances and Hospital
corridors never ever seen anything like
this before Dennis is under huge
pressure have declared a critical
incident that don't deserve to be
treated like this patients should be
able to rely on a basic level of care
there's not a minimum level of service
any day because they've broken the NHS
looking increasingly difficult to heal
they can't just keep letting this happen
[Music]
to University Hospital Coventry and
Warwickshire with over a thousand beds a
busy emergency department and much else
besides and also the place where the
world's first coveted vaccine was given
to a member of the public in December
2020 the nurse here tonight who did that
well since the pandemic resources here
and across the NHS have been stretched
like never before a e departments are
described as War zones staff are
striking public confidence is plummeting
and politicians can't agree what to do
about it so today Sky News is launching
a year-long project with analysis from
two of the UK's leading Health think
tanks the king's fund and the health
Foundation to find solutions to the
crisis gripping the NHS well think of
the Health Service as a sick patient if
you like we'll examine the NHS itself
diagnose what's wrong and at the end of
the year come up with a treatment plan
designed to Breathe new life into an
ailing system tonight then the First
full assessment
for joining me are Skies economics and
data editor Ed Conway our political
editor Beth Rigby and Hugh aldwick from
the health Foundation
and in the audience to give us their
experience from inside the NHS staff
from the hospital and The Wider
Healthcare System here in Coventry
and an audience of around 200 Sky News
viewers all with their own experiences
of the Health Service welcome to all of
you
[Applause]
well before we go any further I'd just
like to find out how many of you have
had recent experience of the NHS
yourselves say after the pandemic put
your hands up if you have
and keep your hands up if for you that
was a positive experience so opt for
positive
okay so perhaps half of you went down
it's certainly a good starting point
well the first Port of Call for many
sick patients is of course the GP so
let's bring in one of our audience
members who is a GP himself Dr Simon
Taylor if you put your hand up we can
see you thank you hello thanks for
joining us certainly oh it's the Gateway
isn't it to the to the Health Service
the GP I know you've been uh a doctor in
the in in a military doctor how does it
compare right now we heard the
description there have it been like a
war zone at the moment well well I I
left the military in 2011 I did
operational tours in Iraq Afghanistan
and Bosnia and uh I would make the point
that uh in certain situations it was
easier for me to admit a seriously ill
patient in a war zone than it is now I
I would give the example a few weeks ago
of where I did a home visit and I saw a
patient I won't go into details who was
clinically obviously developing signs of
a stroke
so I assessed the patient called 999 and
was told it would take 10 hours
to get the patient into Hospital
so I had to make a very quick decision I
went back to my surgery finished my
afternoon Clinic
then came back and took the patient in
my own car to the nearest accident and
emergency department and frankly I don't
see how that is acceptable in
2023. okay well let's put that point and
some of the issues you raised there to
our panel
um he would work I mean the the stories
we're going to hear tonight you know
paint a picture of Crisis but if we
summed up what the problem is you know
the capacity is too low there's not
enough staff and there's too many people
really stuck in hospital well if there's
massive pressures right across the NHS
there's Grim data on Long waits for
hospital but the crisis is in general
Practice in Social care and mental
health is everywhere there's a mix of
issues some are short term clearly the
pandemic has had a big uh big impact on
the NHS a lot of disruption but really
the underlying causes of the problems
are much longer term when they're down
to political choices over the last
decade
and they're about capacity really
there's chronic staff shortages and in
the NHS about 130 000 staff short but
also in adult social care where staff
shortages are even higher there's a
broader pattern of constrained uh
resources you went into the pandemic
with fewer doctors nurses hostel beds
equipment per patient than many uh
comparable countries and we've had a
decade of low spending growth lower than
the historic average and also weak
spending on capital buildings I.T
equipment the things the health system
needs to be productive things that staff
need to do their their job properly and
it's not just about the NHS it's also
about the broader health of the nation
the adult social care system has been
scarred by a decade or more of political
neglect wider public services are
creaking and so these problems interact
they have knock-on effects on each other
and they hold back the system and its
ability to function so it's a mix of
problems but it's not just about the
pandemic it's the long run political
choices that have been made and Ed we
know the the NHS runs hot doesn't it if
you put it that way but capacity is
straining in every area and the easiest
measure I guess is beds sometimes and we
know that in the last you know 30 years
the number of beds in the UK is halved
it hasn't I mean I should say you know
if we take a step back I mean part of
the part of the reason that we're doing
this at Sky News and the reason that
we've we've given it so long you know
we're a journalistic organization we
wouldn't normally conduct an
investigation or indeed a project that
takes quite as long as this one is just
because the the scale not just of the
issues but the you know the scale of of
this organization is so enormous and to
some extent you know the NHS well it has
been in crisis since its very first days
you know the the earliest kind of crises
were not long after the foundation of
the NHS and ever since then it has been
said to be in crisis you know if you
look back through newspaper cuttings but
even so when you look at most of those
metrics and you know I was putting
together charts in advance of of of this
show and and I I actually kind of just
kept adding more and more more of them
quite scary just in terms of whether
it's waiting times whether it's looking
at kind of hospital beds whether it's
comparisons with other countries around
the world not entirely it's not across
the board you know in some senses there
are many things we can be very proud of
but in other senses there's lots of
strain and that comes back to the fact
that when we're talking about you know
the health system as a whole it's a lens
on the country and many of the bigger
issues we're facing whether it's
demographic whether it's the fiscal
issue right now so how much money we
have to spend on it whether it's just
where we are right now after the
pandemic
um and when you consider all of that
those are such enormous issues that
there is no single answer there's no
single chart I can show you on this it's
going to kind of tell that story but
right now so many of those different
metrics when you look across the piece
are definitely very strained and we'll
look into more of those as the program
continues what about Staffing we've
heard some of the shortages issues if
you were doing a situation report for
government right now Beth there'd be red
flags there would be red flags all
across the system as well Anna and when
I report about this in my life as
political editor the two stats that
really always stick out to me is this
7.2 million on waiting lists just the
scale of demand and people's needs not
being met and then the Royal College of
emergency medicine said recently that
they estimated three to five hundred
people a week were dying uh because of
backlogs and not being getting seen
Quicken offers as you as you were
talking about and
um I should say the government and the
NHS refute that figure just to be clear
but in terms of all of that what would
you say about Staffing well the
government would say uh that they've
recruited nearly 25 percent more staff
since uh 20 10 80
000 uh more nurses and doctors but it
just cannot keep up with the demands of
an age in population a more complicated
Health needs
Labor's point of view they have put out
what they would describe as their retail
offer ahead of the general election and
that is their plan to abolish non-dom
tax which they would say uh would say
create 3.2 billion which they would then
use uh to double uh junior doctor places
more nurses and more Health visitors 30
000 more staff but the obvious thing is
that could be well they might not win
the election and then that's the middle
of the decade and the staff shortages
are now that the other thing I would say
about it is part of the problem is the
tight labor market means that doctors
and nurses and NHS staff that are fed up
uh with with below inflation pay Rises
and and a decade of real-time pay cuts
they do have the option to go to other
sectors and actually I had an email from
a junior doctor today actually uh
telling me about how although they are
training um retention and morale is that
a rock bottom people are looking to
leave the health service at the very
point that the government need them to
stay I can see some of you with your
hands up promise we will come to you I
just want to do one more thing before
that if that's okay because I can see
people are itching to get in uh straight
away we've talked about the gateway to
the NHS being GPS the other way of
course that people come in is via
ambulance so I now want to talk to James
Jackman
um who tried to get in James if you put
your hand up as well hello there and um
it's been it's been you want to talk
sorry yeah
um I want to talk to James Jackman and
uh you know the difficulties that you
faced
they were sorry yes oh yeah
um yeah I was told there would be a
delay
when I called for an ambulance for my
partner and
um
that took nearly 11 hours
which
caught shocking
and tell us about your wife Hannah then
she she wasn't very well on the evening
um
I was convinced more than she was that
she wasn't very well
otherwise I would have
which I suggested taking up by a car but
she wasn't having none of it
um
but uh yeah I
called the ambulance for it and um
she she went into the hospital
we had a delay going from the ambulance
into the hospital itself
um
and then as
she progressively gotten worse we had a
delight to get her on to Critical Care
um
yeah
James we know this is really difficult
for you because it's so recent uh it was
December the 18th that you called the
hospital wasn't it you called 999 uh you
called it 720 they finally arrived at 6
15 in the morning we know this is very
difficult for you we appreciate you
you're sharing that story with us
um I know it wasn't this area but let me
go to Andy Hardy who's the chief
executive here
um you know how common are stories like
that are people either waiting at him
for an ambulance or the ambulance is
outside the hospital and they can't get
in here
there is pressure
especially as well the whole system was
already heard and that often sort of
magnified when these ambulance is
sitting outside hospitals who need to
offload their patients because they're
often waiting to get to another patient
and then we have certainly seen that but
we know that the challenges are
multifactorial hospitals are full
because they can't discharge patients
um do we have Services outside of
hospitals which actually could deal with
some of the people who are coming into
Hospital who don't need to come into
Hospital
so we need to act as a system not just
hospitals on our own working with
ambulances working with all other
providers in the system and social care
social care is a really important role
to play in this and that's the way we
can avoid such stories in the future
we missed the first part of what you
said you were giving your sympathy I
know to to James and his family and to
everybody who's been in that situation
and you know we'll wholeheartedly offer
our condolences as well to you oh well
let's hear more about the pressures then
on the ambulance and what they've been
like from the people on the front line
of the service who take those 999 calls
um across one Becky Johnson is in the
control center for the West Midlands
ambulance survey in Derby and Becky I
know that you've spent a lot of time
with the ambulance service over the past
week or so you know what's it been like
and how is it now
well this is the main Hub where 999
ambulance calls come to in the West
Midlands and it's these call handlers
that have to try to find those resources
to send to those most critical calls and
it's been incredibly difficult this
winter let me give you an idea of the
kind of Weights that people have
experienced uh the longest way to West
Midlands ambulance had outside a
hospital so they couldn't get into a
full a e last month 32 hours 57 minutes
a patient was waiting in the back of an
ambulance now that means of course the
ambulance can't then get back on the
road to respond to other critical calls
this month it's a slightly better
picture it's the longest week this month
has been 11 hours 57 minutes and that's
reflecting a national picture actually
that things are easing slightly but only
slightly ambulance Handover should be
done within 15 minutes I've been
speaking to the guys here to find out
why things are easing just that little
bit and there's a series of reasons they
say they're seeing fewer flu covered and
strep a cases thankfully but they've all
also put in place measures that help
them to cope with these unprecedented
pressures since some of the busiest a e
departments we've now got Advanced
paramedics from the ambulance service
working with Healthcare assistants in
New areas that have been set up to treat
patients so that ambulances can drop the
patient off and get back on the road and
they're in the care essentially of a
paramedic within the hospital there is
also concern here that the call numbers
aren't as much as they would be
expecting at this time of year and when
I was out with Cruz a few days ago we
went to a call an elderly man who'd
Fallen two days earlier he had a serious
arm injury but his wife said she felt
bad and delayed calling 999 because she
said it wasn't a matter of life and
death now that's where some of the
messaging around strike days has led to
people not calling and also because of
what people are hearing because they're
hearing that they could get stuck in an
ambulance for hours on end or they could
get stuck in a corridor in a hospital
and therefore people may well be feeling
scared to call 99 9 when they really do
need help so the messages from the
message from the workers here are please
obviously don't add to the pressures if
you don't need them but if you do need
them they are here to take your call
Becky thank you very much indeed well
Hugh I mean if you think of it like a
pipeline there's a blockage the whole
system backs up that that's kind of the
impression we're getting yeah and it's
not just one pipe it's lots of
interconnected pipes James I was really
sorry to hear about your experience
ambulance long ambulance waiting times
is a good example of these blockages so
that's off on the front door into a
hospital but if you think about the back
door hospitals are really struggling to
discharge patients out into the
community or home because it's a lack of
services or support in the community
that means there's beds full of patients
that don't necessarily need to be there
which means you've got a lot of beds
full in hospital uh High bed occupancy
which can be unsafe which means you've
got patients waiting in a e to be
admitted to a bed and that's why you've
got ambulances waiting and a small
pressure somewhere in that system can
have a big knock-on effect somewhere
else so the sort of scary data we see on
waiting times in hospitals just reflects
the pressure we see right across the
system in general Practice in Social
care and mental health everywhere and
that means the solutions are not just
about hospitals they're about that wider
system as well and then if you stand
back even further the NHS is one bit of
a bigger system of public services that
keep us healthy that later on dictate
when we need health services
um like Local Government Services Public
Health but parts of that system have
been eroded over the last decade which
means the NHS is often left to pick up
the pieces well ambulance wait times one
good example as a measure the other has
been excess deaths which we've heard a
lot about and certainly you know records
are being broken which is you know just
the worst thing to hear they haven't and
so long after after the pandemic and
these numbers each week are deeply
depressing and let me let me show you
though we've got a few charts that we
can show you on ambulance wait times
because those numbers are incredibly
Stark at the moment this this is showing
you the mean waiting time so it's you
know obviously different different
people's experiences may vary for
different categories so from category
one through to category four so so
deemed the most severe risks to to life
through to to lesser severe risks and
this is what look at those bars that's
how many minutes or indeed hours people
having to wait before the pandemic so
you might see that as being a kind of
relatively decent kind of record here
but look at what's happened so that's
January 2020. look at what's happened
and where we are now look at these bars
so that's where we were uh just in the
last actually it should say in December
of last year look at how far those bars
have gone up you're talking about four
hours wait on category three and these
are averages so you know James's
experiences unfortunately mirrored by
those many people who are having to wait
even longer than these average uh
waiting times and Andy was referring to
that you know that issue of the blockage
and you know how many people are in bed
and in hospital for long periods of time
partly because you can't get those
Pathways out uh of Hospital well these
lines are just showing you the number of
beds over given periods uh so so each of
the different lines is a different year
going back the last few years
um that's what you might consider to be
to be a normal level of bed occupancy of
long bed occupancy over seven days and
now I'm going to bring up this uh latest
year that we're in at the moment so look
at that red line it is just way out of
whack with anything from previous recent
history and that is just I think it's
underlining the difficulty of clearing
those beds so that people can actually
occupy them and the fact that it's at
the end it's the exit to hospital and
it's also entrance to hospital as well
well Beth the government has refused to
call this a crisis and blamed a
respiratory on this plus the problem of
social care as well they have so far not
done a deal with those unions who are
striking physios today as we heard
um how would you characterize how they
are handling this
well in terms of how they're handling it
it is a standoff between health workers
and the government and I'm afraid to say
and I check in on it pretty much every
day uh it is stalemate and there is no
there is no movement so we have a
striped day of ambulance workers and
nurses the fast day both together on
February the 6th and and I'm afraid to
say that when I check in with government
it all of these strikes are still going
to continue the government's position
has not changed which is they will not
discuss the current year pay deal that's
the year until April 2023 they will
discuss the pay settlement for the year
April 2023 to April 2024 and so in terms
of all of the stresses and strains and
James I was so sorry
to hear your story it doesn't seem like
there is going to be a resolution
um and as you said the government don't
want to call it a Christ crisis but
health workers are certainly calling it
the worst crisis in history as our labor
um and it's not at the moment and I'm
afraid there's no resolution inside and
just quickly the first two and a bit
rows here are those who work either at
this hospital or The Wider Health
Community
um if you could put your hands up if you
thought this was a crisis what you've
experienced so far in uh possibly the
end of December and uh early January so
does one two three four five more of you
put your hands up so now the audience
does put your hand up here I will come
to you I promise absolutely
um let's just uh speak now to you uh
doctor he who is uh Chief registrar and
uh speaks on behalf of Junior doctors
here um how's it been has it been for
you then and your team
there's been a huge increase in the
numbers of
um patients outside of our usual medical
spaces and and that's just a reflection
on the amount of illness going around
and that are unable to to get people out
of the hospital so so yeah it's been
worse than usual for sure okay doctor he
thank you very much indeed well we've
heard about the the problems getting an
ambulance but even if you try to go
yourself it's often increasingly hard to
be admitted to hospital and that was
certainly the case for Yusuf Mahmoud
Nazir and his uncles
here in the audience with us if you
could put your hand out for me hi
um tell us about what happened with your
your nephew I know you we've spoken to
you before on Sky News and you told us
then that he had severe tonsillitis so
so what happened and what did you try to
do yeah Yusuf
um originally went in to the GPS with a
sore throat
um the GP diagnosed me with a
tonsillitis he then went uh same day he
got quite severe
was taken to the hospital and waited
approximately about eight nine hours to
be seen he was told that the from the
hospital that there's only one doctor
working on the night
um who's looking after the children and
also the uh after midnight he looks
after the adults
um Yusuf was then seen why the doctor
was told he was one of the worst
tonsillitis he's ever seen
it was then given antibiotics and sent
home
we then fetched him back again a day
later and he was then given to the GPS
and he was then told that he needs to be
on IV antibiotics urgently
um his condition is quite severe with
his tonsillitis so we we demanded the
hospital to put him on IV they said
they've got no doctors available no beds
available so they can't do anything so
they didn't they refused to put him on
IV antibiotics we then taken him to a
different hospital we had no choice so
we're taking him to a different
Children's Hospital
um it was then put on IV antibiotics but
his infection spreaded to his chest he
spread it to his lungs caused him
pneumonia and then use of Yusuf died
and do you think he would have died if
he'd if he'd had treatment do you firmly
blame the lack of treatment it was
definitely a lack of treatment because
when Yusuf went to the other Hospital
the Children's Hospital in Sheffield
Yusuf was given IV antibiotics as soon
as he entered the ale Department the use
of the day after was set up he was
playing his iPad it was a little bit
active it was eating ear a little bit
and he had drunk a little bit of water
so that IV antibiotic did work but it
was too late the infection spreaded to
his chest and his lungs and then he
caused him pneumonia and then he just
had organ failure from there so it was
we believe as a family and we do believe
that if he was given the antibiotics
when we was really begging him for the
treatment we was I was on the phone for
10 minutes and 43 seconds begging the
award to keep Lee can we fetch him
please just to give him IV antibiotics
the GP said he urgently needs it but the
GP said we stuck we're not allowed to
refer anybody to the ward we've been
told we could not refer any patience to
the ward we've got to send everybody to
the ene
um so we do we do we do think that if we
did get his antibiotics when he needed
them the IV antibiotics user would have
been alive today
well the hospital trust has told us that
an independent investigation is underway
but you know you heard the reaction of
the audience we all really feel for for
you and your family and um you know it's
it's a it's a very hard thing to deal
with you know here you hear stories like
that you know and uh very bravely told
here in this audience if there's one
thing that could change right now to
make things better what would it be well
look unfortunately the problems in the
health system were long in the making so
they're going to be long in the fixing
too and politicians have to be honest
about that there's not a Magic Bullet a
single thing that's going to make a
difference right now priorities uh
there's a couple of priorities probably
in the short term one is social care I
think expanding capacity outside of
hospitals in Social care in the
community could help free up some space
in hospital but also give people the
support they need part of that should
involve improving pay for social care
workers mostly women among the lowest
paid workers in the UK experience
shocking levels of of of poverty and
deprivation doing that's going to
require investment social care sector
often gets small drips of money from
government when actually it needs to
turn on the tap to support that sector
but also ultimately Health and Social
care are a people business we've got
chronic staff shortages we've got
challenges with retention with burnout
over the longer run government needs to
put in place a strategy for recruiting
retaining enough staff in the future
astonishingly it still doesn't have one
backed by funding and that's what this
system needs I mean Beth that's exactly
the point isn't it about Recruitment and
Retention and yet you've got striking
staff and the difficulty is of course
that Health takes up an increasing
proportion of the entire wealth of this
country and as it got to the point that
some members of the conservative party
possibly or others are suggesting that
as enough is enough and that's when you
start to say well how else do we fund it
absolutely and actually when you look at
Health spending as a percentage of
government day-to-day spending it's now
at about 44 of day-to-day spending and
it and it's set to rise to about 50 just
under 50 by the next German election
with the conservatives put in as you
might have seen an additional 6.6
billion over the next two years and the
Autumn statement
but demand is just outstripping Supply
there is a growing discussion amongst
politicians about it's time to have an
honest conversation as they would put it
about funding I interviewed Sajid Javid
the former Health secretary at the end
of last year and he said we need to talk
about how we are funding the NHS and
have an honest conversation do we
increase General taxation do we move to
a hybrid model such as in Germany or
France where you pay for some services
or you have insurance one former Health
Minister said to me the other day that
they think it is inevitable after the
next general election regardless who
wins that that you might have to start
charging for some Services
um that I can see people shaking their
heads because the principle of the NHS
is free at the point of use the issue I
think Anna is that politically for both
parties no one wants to have the
conversation because it involves hard
choices about raising taxation people
want to win an election and they don't
want to put that on the public but the
problem is as you're saying then the
problem doesn't get solved and it's the
same with social care which we can we
can talk about a bit later on as well in
terms of how that's funded yeah
absolutely I know lots of people now
want to get in perhaps we could um speak
to the lady in the pink shirt down here
actually if you just wait one second
while our microphone comes and then uh
yes
oh yes do continue yet I don't think
a turnover of Health secretaries has
helped us so you were speaking there
about sahaja Javid well tonight I'm a
pharmacist I'm chair of the royal
pharmaceutical Society in England and we
haven't heard about Pharmacy this
evening but Sergey Javid
understood that Pharmacy First which is
this scheme which would enable
pharmacists to provide care which
shouldn't people shouldn't be seeing a
GP for in in the pharmacy on the High
Street normally a 20-minute walkway from
most people but we've been waiting and
waiting for that and we really are
hoping it'll be coming soon but we've
seen the turnover of Health secretaries
hasn't helped us in that regard one last
point of our just may we've heard
tonight about the cost of living crisis
well health inequalities have risen
during the pandemic and we know that our
Pharmacy teams are key to tackling that
helping people understand the importance
of vaccinations for example but at this
stage with the number of pharmacies
closing down due to underfunding that's
another pressure that's going to be be
on the rest of the Health Service so we
need a whole systems approach which
recognizes as well that it's not just
the doctors in general practice we are
all the team in Primary Care supporting
secondary care but we are tired as well
and it's Relentless the pressure that's
on our teams thank you I wonder if we
can take some more from the audience the
gentleman there in the suit actually yes
you there yeah thank you just wait one
second tell the microwave yeah okay yes
thank you very much I'm a GP in Coventry
I've been working for last 35 years
and I came from abroad I've established
myself as a GP I know all the pressure
NHS has the way things are going on I
believe that NHS isn't decline for last
10 years and nothing has been done
I've got two sons so just recently
qualified and they are working at Junior
doctors my question is what has any
government done in last 10 years
to see that homegrown
doctors nurses paramedics are going to
work in this country and why are they
looking for important doctors from
abroad all the time and then the
question is when the doctors are working
or anybody is working they're not paying
them they're selling properly and
they're not treating them with respect
I'm quite scared
I I believe a lot of children who
qualify now will immigrate to Australia
or Canada because in this country
there's so much of policing for the
doctors anytime you raise a voice they
start using the clinical governance
issue and a lot of young doctors are
scared to live in this country and
they're trying to immigrate and I'm very
scared that my children also will be
doing the same okay and and we know that
the government has got a cap on the
numbers it wants through training which
was relieved during the pandemic but
it's now back and in fact they started
insisting again saying to the the
medical colleges that they would be
fined if they don't actually stick to
that cap but that point being made there
that a lack of long-term plan has meant
an over-reliance on foreign doctors and
nurses in this country yet is that
something we've seen yeah and I mean you
know there's there's in a sense there's
kind of two well I mean there's many
more than two this is kind of you know
multiple polarity but you know there's
there's the Staffing sides and then
there's also the kind of investment in
the facilities side and these two things
have been enormously underfunded in
comparison with you know historical
record going back recently in a sense
the more Stark Side is that facilities
side I mean for instance a couple of
charts we can we can show you first of
all looking at the number of hospital
beds per thousand of the population well
the UK is way below where most other
countries around the world I don't know
if we can bring up that shot but the UK
is way above where most other countries
around the world are when it comes to
hospital beds per thousand of the
population now there it is so this this
again looking around the developed world
there's the UK's bar kind of way below
most other countries around the world
look at the number of CT scanners uh per
million of the population we're we're
just way at the bottom for that as well
and talking to this question of just the
investment in the facilities they're
looking kind of taking a step back when
you look at the amount of capital
investment so just the amount that the
government is putting in you can
probably see a pattern here that blue
area is other countries so other major
countries around the world and just how
much as a percentage of GDP they're
putting in the governments are putting
in and it's been rising and rising and
rising and the red line is the UK and
you can see how the UK was tracking
along with most other countries around
the world then not uncoincidentally came
in 2010 and suddenly that line was just
way out of whack with everywhere else
around the world and you know there's
there's many ways of looking at the
impact of austerity but this is a a
pretty Stark charge but what's really
interesting as well about this chart is
if you ask labor if you win the next
election will you invest more money into
the NHS they will not say they will not
commit to that and I tried very hard
with Andrew Rayner an interview recently
to get her to commit to that and what
they will talk about as you were talking
about is reform and reorganization and
you say yeah I get you you can make the
argument about using more pharmacies and
changing provision of care and how you
do it but does it also need more funding
both Health experts would say yes but a
labor government incoming or a labor
government hoping or a labor party
hoping to be a government they will not
commit to more funding because they're
worried that if they start to commit to
that then they get into a row with the
conservative parties they're going to be
careless with the nation's finances you
know how the record goes at running up
to a general election and because I know
we're not having the conversation yeah
but the nation feels broke because of
the series of shocks that have hit it
from the financial crisis you know
before 2010 uh brexit as well the
pandemic and now the Ukraine Wars so
it's a series of things that have
squeezed the economy isn't it
um lots of what we've talked about has
been acute care there's chronic issues
too and ongoing care too that hospitals
have to manage some areas just have to
keep on running a Wisconsin's Health
correspondent Ashish Joshi is uh joining
us now from the dialysis unit and and
this is part of you know the the nuts
and bolts of hospitals you know quite
aside from whatever crises that just
have to keep functioning Ashish
that's right they're offering
life-changing life-saving care in this
renal unit up to 10 000 patients kidney
patients are looked after here it's one
of the busiest in the country 200
patients come here every day for their
dialysis and you need to keep services
like this going through a pandemic and
that presents challenges not just during
a Health crisis like the pandemic but
the Health crisis the NHS is facing now
and all of these patients who come here
anna need expert nurses and expert
doctors and I'm glad to say that we're
going to talk to matron Linda Mott and
Dr Krishna who are from this dialysis
unit this renal unit let me ask you
first Linda March we've been hearing
from our studio panel and the audience
there about the pressures on hospitals
how do you protect a service like this
one from the pressures that the rest of
the hospital is facing or are you not
immune to it do you feel the same
pressures here yeah we absolutely feel
the same pressures there's been a
certain increase in the demand on beds
this year when that's been felt from the
front door up to our boards and into the
outpatient departments as well and
coupled with the fact that we've had
staff sickness as well has made life
quite difficult for us here at uhcw and
however I think we do what we do best
and that's for our patients first and we
continue to deliver a really high
quality service and we're very proud of
the team that we have here at uhcw yeah
there are pressures which
flu and coveted Brink pandemics
but also now you're gearing up towards
having this service remaining through
industrial action you haven't been
affected by the nurses like at this
trust but the ambulance work is going up
that will put pressure on you and the
services you provide here yeah
absolutely we've had I think two days of
ambulance strikes here already and a day
of physio strikes um which has happened
today and I think we just look to
forward plan everything we put
contingency plans in place so that
patients receive the care that they
really need okay good thank you then the
Christian let me talk to you about
kidney failure chronic kidney disease is
your demand Rising for from patients for
your services it's been an incredible
demand race in patients presenting late
and uh there's been an incredible demand
for the service as well but as a team
we've managed to put contingency plans
we've created more hot clinics and more
spaces to see these patients because of
the pandemic patients have been
presenting a bit late so we've been
trying to to put in alert systems to see
if we can recognize early and and
prevent them progressing to chronic
kidney disease actually okay we've been
talking about the future the NHS elderly
patients are you geared up towards
looking after an aging population
the pandemic has certainly taught us
lessons we faced a lot of adversities we
facilitate about 200 dialysis sessions a
day as you said and we were thrown into
situations where we had to barrier these
patients and also prevent the infection
spreading from one patient to the other
and that has taught us a lot of lessons
and credit to my incredible team that
will come come out stronger and we're
prepared for the future hard lessons
you'll carry into the future Krishna
Linda thank you very much to Frontline
doctors and nurses working in chronic
kidney control here at the renal unit
and they just have to keep working
through pandemics through a Health
crisis and through the industrial action
that's coming next
Ashley thank you very much indeed well
even leaving hospital can be problematic
too especially if it is to go to some
other care settings we've heard about
the sort of blockages in the system that
was certainly the experience of Sarah
Templeton another member of our audience
and we heard about infection control and
Sarah I think you're you know your
experience combines both of those tell
us what happened well it was horrendous
excuse me my mum went into Hospital on
the 11th of November she had Parkinson's
but it was very very well managed and
there was no problem with Parkinson's
she used to fall over a lot it was very
common she's fall over three or four
times a day but this one time she fell
over she did a bit more damage than
normal and the doctor was worried so he
sent her to hospital because he thought
she had a stroke she actually hadn't had
a stroke she'd punctured a lung and that
was why she couldn't
um breathe and couldn't talk so she went
into hospital
um for
um she actually had six fractured ribs a
punctured lung and a damaged spleen she
ended up staying in there seven weeks
during that seven weeks we were told at
one point she had covid so she was moved
I I do stress we kept her covered free
all the way through covid and we've kept
her flu free as well we've done
everything that the government told us
to do but in the hospital we were told
you've got covered she was moved towards
we all had to wear masks then three days
later I said to a doctor uh his mum
how's my mum doing with the covid is she
over it and they looked up he went your
mother's never had covid and put the
thing down so we were like seriously
okay anyway we're now four weeks in they
say Your mother is medically fit uh
medically fit apart from the Parkinson's
which is managed
um and she can be moved to a discharge
an assessment center so we're like
fantastic but it didn't happen she sat
she sat she sat she was bored stupid she
wanted to move and then she got a chest
infection and then she got the flu and
then she got pneumonia and then we sat
holding her hand while she died on
December the 30th and she didn't need to
die my mum didn't need to die my mum was
perfectly well she was perfectly well
for three weeks she was bored she wanted
to come out of the hospital and two
doctors I cannot fault the doctors and
the nurses they were all amazing all of
them but two doctors told me on two
separate occasions I'm really sorry
Sarah but this is what happens when you
come into hospital now if you come in
and you're elderly or you've got lower
immune system for whatever reason you
will get the chest infection you will
get the flu you will get pneumonia and
you will die and I said to both of them
why didn't you tell us that because we
would have broken her out of here we
would not have left her here we thought
she was in the best place for seven
weeks we went in every day for seven
weeks and held her hand and then I had
to sit and watch her with masks on her
face gasping for breath and she died
gasping for breath and that's how she
died because there was nowhere to take
her and they wouldn't let us take her
home because she was under a section 42
had to be the responsibility of the
local Authority but but the local
Authority didn't look after her so she
ended up staying and dying for no reason
I'm so sorry that you heard the gasps
again from the audience here didn't you
we're so sorry to to hit to hear that
and just that didn't happen in this area
just to point out but if for all of you
in the audience would you feel confident
in having an older relative go to
hospital right now if you could put your
hands up for uh yes you would
yes you would be confident
so the medical staff would at the
frontier and one member of the audience
there
um yes you want to come in you've been
trying all programs yes
I'll keep this very short the question
asks can the NHS survive Phil Brown
South Shields I hope that it does
um my life was saved at seven weeks of
age with a cerebral hemorrhage four
weeks of age with a cerebral hemorrhage
and I was fortunate enough to nurse for
44 years and represent sick children's
interests for the whole of the United
Kingdom
give a kid a chance this is what the NHS
can do the bevinite part of me my dad
was a coal miner and he said and if I
don't get it right I'll try and
paraphrase it the NHS Will Survive for
as long as there are people even now who
are prepared to fight for it and then
thank you
and
just just to end because I'm not
privileged in nursing I have been moved
by the people who have given their
testimony
Think Tank I'm like rust I never sleep
give us back an elected nurse's Council
take away the parking charges give us a
four day week we will graft
three days
three days reflectory time
have a nurse Bank not an agency get the
money back and watch what all NHS staff
can do what I accept we are on our chin
straps thank you so much okay
and just quickly yes the man with the
Bobble hat sorry to uh describe yeah
hi there I'm a student and I'm looking
to start my adult Nursing degree in
September this year
um and I alongside a lot of my
colleagues I've worked with and also
other students um are really worried
about the future of the NHS and we are
the future of nursing we we choose and
we are passionate to do that however
there is so many aspects and there's so
many things in the public sector and
social sector that really really worry
us and for the current staff in the NHS
and the public sector I commend you I we
all commend you um as that the youth and
the young people of the country and my
question is what what is going to be put
in place
um through our government and and with
the NHS to attract people to be a nurse
and also when when they're attracted
into the profession how are we going to
keep them how are you going to keep them
because so many people are leaving and I
I as well as my colleagues see so many
things so many people leaving the NHS to
go into private sectors and it's it's
scary it's dangerous
well thank you thank you for both of you
for your contributions we'll come to
more of your promise Hugh just on the
point of older care that we talked about
there uh we know that half the people
over 65 when we learned this during
covid have two or more comorbidities and
two-thirds of those people who are the
ones who end up in in impatience in
hospital you know that is a critical
part of this conversation is that is our
demographics isn't it yeah and it's also
a success it's good that people are
living longer
um it's a success of modern medicine but
they're also growing older with more
complex conditions and the question is
how do you look after those people and
help them to live a healthy life this is
not just a challenge for the NHS it's
countries across the world that need to
do that
um this brings us back to social care
and one of the gaping holes in our our
welfare state uh we've got a social care
system that looks after all the disabled
people of all ages but also older folks
too
um and at the moment it's a threadbare
safety net it's Sony available
state-funded care for people with the
highest needs the lowest means many
people go without the care they need
something people face very high costs
we've had successive governments that
have promised to reform the system and
then success of governments that have
delayed and then ditched reform this
government's uh no different
um basically means politicians are
choosing to prolong a major public
policy failure that means many older and
disabled people are not getting the
support they need so the health system
has to work out how it manages care for
people with complex needs that's better
integration of services between GPS and
hospitals that's more investment in
prevention early intervention to keep
people well at home but it also needs
political will to actually fundamentally
reform our social care system to make it
fit for the future okay now then of
course health problems can go on for a
long time that's not only for older
people too many younger people have
long-term conditions that need looking
after in the case of Paul Michael at
will Bryce that care is for their sons
Levy and Lucas and I I don't know which
of you would prefer to to speak um
Michael perhaps but you adopted twins
did you not that have a range of
problems and for you it's been a
struggle to pull the care you need out
of the system
yeah so we feel like we've got to beg
for everything from the boys from like
two-year-olds so a three-year-old that
were diagnosed with severe autism and
then the birth started with seizures one
after another so they're both severely
epileptic as well
um so just for the the care for the boys
um we've had to fight for like over
Christmas we were left with no syringes
because we feed them medical like fiber
drinks for a syringe we're all left we
know syringes because they've passed
them to Adult Services now they're 16.
um when they needed support from comes
leave I only got that last year for his
mental health and that's at age 16. we
referred him 10 years prior to that so
we waited 10 years to have support from
comms
um but then you always say about early
intervention and here we are families
like ourselves in the UK that are
fighting for the correct support of
these children and it's physically not
there twin identical twin boys both with
the same difficulties one that can get
the Cannabis treatment for his epilepsy
the other can't leave I can get it
because he's been ventilated but Lucas
can't because he's not seen as serious
enough and it all comes down to money
and costing all the time and there are
so many families out there out there in
the UK that are in our situation that
are caring full time for such children
with complex needs and the support and
help is not there and they're having to
fight constantly and some parents
haven't got that fight within them let
alone dealing with the child themselves
so we deal with a lot of Charities and
things getting passed to Charities to
fundraise to diagnose children with
autism why can't RNA just do that why is
it getting past the Charities and to
have to fundraise for that why do we
have to fight for cannabis treatment
when the rep ellipse is supposed to be a
Levi's on six different epileptic drugs
it's been on life support machine before
we've nearly lost him and we have to say
we thank the doctors and nurses for all
you do but the money is not there we're
getting passed from Pillar To Post
there's people those social care saying
we don't fund this try social care
they're passing you from Pillar To Post
to get the equipment support the
medications like the being on wheelchair
waiting lists for over six months for a
new chair we can't physically carry them
now if they have a seizure the nearly
17. but you're having to manage the
children themselves and it's so complex
and a lot of doctors listening to this
in pediatric will understand that it's
so complex and it can be a case of life
and life and death and if we don't sort
out who's going to look after these
children because in the end they'll have
to go into specialized Provisions that
will cost thousands of pounds yet at
home by keeping them in a family
environment you're doing an
extraordinary job and you know we we all
wish it was easier for you and that goes
back to what exactly I mean best where
are we now you know secure stama has
said that the NHS is no longer an out of
bound Shrine we've had a former Health
secretary Javed talking about a
voluntary contribution 20 pounds he said
for GP
does it feel like politicians are edging
towards reform of the Health Service
I think that what will happen is that
this will all be put on Ice until after
the next general election which will
probably happen about 18 months time and
as you were just talking about when it
comes to social care Boris Johnson did
have a plan for social care it did
involve a tax rise it would have raised
12 billion a year that would have been
front loaded to the NHS and then moved
into social care and the policy got
scrapped one thing I would say is
positive about all of this tonight and I
I did an interview this week with um
Justin Welby the Archbishop country
because the Church of England has done a
commission on reimagining social care in
which they talk about having an NHS
style Universal provision
is that the crisis that the NHS is in
and the love that people have for it and
you can see it in the audience here is
that it is provoking a national
conversation about how do we reform the
NHS what do politicians need to do
so I think the discussion is being had
but I have to say the hard politics of
it are these are very difficult
political issues they become politicized
and it means it's very difficult for
politicians to do anything that isn't
short-term with an eye on winning a
general election and then maybe having
the conversation afterwards we're
running out of time I do apologize let's
go back to your Bevan quote shall we
it'll survive if there's enough people
to fight for it are there enough people
to fight for it you of course and the
public has really strong support for the
core principles of the NHS it's free at
the point of use available to all
predominantly tax funded a lot of this
political rhetoric about radical reform
of the NHS is a distraction we we talked
about the problems in the NHS today
they're playing to see a decade of under
investment neglect of social care not
enough staff the solutions are mostly
unglamorous pretty well known more staff
more investment better integration of
services things we've been talking
talking about more capital investment
more equipment the NHS has done this
before in the 90s long waiting times a
government invests in the health system
it boosts staff performance improves a
lot of the ideas are not based on
evidence switching to a social insurance
model it's going to be a massive waste
of time and money no evidence would say
it would lead to better outcomes and the
public don't want it the politicians
should focus on the real problems facing
the NHS staff shortages low investment
and think about what they need to do
about it and be honest with the public
that's going to take time and it's going
to take investment but of course it's
worth doing listen to the audience uh
today yeah so are you saying yes yeah
NHS can survive and in its present form
yeah the model of the NHS is not the
issue here it's how politicians have
treated to the NHS
well a final thought from Ed and I don't
want to end on a downer is it is it
unaffordable I'm sorry to say we talked
about living longer the expense of
medicines all the new technology that's
coming through can our nation afford it
well I mean yeah we can we can we can
absolutely afford it and you know what
what it needs is a case of politicians
thinking in the long term and part of
the issue and it's not just Health but
part of the issue with this with also
with climate change and what we do with
the you know the energy transition with
what we're doing with the kind of state
of the the benefit system in the UK is
that for a long time you know we haven't
had politicians who are willing to look
beyond the next few years you know the
state of our transport system as well
and so were we to get kind of you know
to have politicians who did want to
think in the longer run there are plenty
of things that could be done and you
mentioned some of them hopefully over
the course of the next year we'll be
looking at many of those those kind of
opportunities there are opportunities
there are enormous challenges and it's
hard to mentioning you know cover data
and bind every chart that I show I know
there are heart-wrenching stories and
we've heard some of them tonight and
unfortunately the proportion of those
stories has gone up it needs a systemic
look at this we're going to start doing
that at Sky News and politicians who are
willing to look beyond the next few
years unfortunately we don't have many
of them at the moment well let's uh
let's ask our audience I know you've all
got your hands up and I apologize we
can't get to everybody but just on that
point of whether you'd be willing to pay
more we're not talking about
privatization here but the idea of a
small personal extra contribution to
keep it would you put your hands up for
Yes
okay that's yes and then our substantive
question of the night can the NHS
survive in its present form uh yes for
up
that's nearly all of you I have to say
that's nearly real which they will be
heartened to hear in the 75th year of
the NHS which comes up this July
um thank you so much for your
contribution that's it for for now but
do you remember it is only the start of
a project that will last all year we've
had the initial consultation about the
state of the NHS and over the coming
months with analysis from the health
foundation and from the king's fund will
diagnose what's making the NHS struggle
and work out how to treat it if it is to
survive as you want it to I think my
thanks to our panel this evening Hugh
alderwick Beth Rigby and Ed Conway
uh thank you to to Coventry and
Warwickshire hospitals and all the staff
here tonight who have been so very
helpful over the two days we've been
here we're very grateful thank you very
much indeed
um yeah they deserve a clap
and in particular I did want to thank
those members of our audience who've
been sharing their stories about the
state of the NHS it's not easy for you
we understand that thank you also for
watching a very good night from all of
us here and don't forget a year-long
project stay tuned for Sky News plenty
more to come
foreign